And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
We'll just jump right in and get to your questions.
First question, should we be checking our IGF1 levels?
If so, is that a blood test?
So, if you wanna check your IGF1 levels,
yes, that is a blood test.
You could order it, along with any other blood test marker.
But I don't think it's very costly.
The only reason why we don't have it standard
in our wellness panel is I think it's...
I don't know if it's a very valuable thing to test
because those values can function it.
So, whenever something jumps up a dial,
the value of that test goes down.
For instance, a lot of people will have thyroid issues
and they'll go to a doctor who will only test for TSH.
Completely un-valuable because TSH will go up and down
throughout a day.
So, any of what time of day you get your TSH level tested
and will vary.
You could do a TSH blood test every hour of a day
and it would have a different value.
So, there's some things that are extremely valuable to check.
So, you can get a tested, I'm gonna test it.
I don't know if there's a lot of value getting the test.
And my local practitioner said my microbiome
in my colon is off.
Maybe why it's showing up inflamed in my PET scan.
She tested me for systemic formulas.
Mucosaogenic, which is supposed to be a root care,
colonic, permeability type supplement.
I saw an ingredient with el glutamine.
So, she tested again.
It also asked if I also asked if it could hurt me.
And the answer was no.
In two capsules, there's 12 milligrams zinc,
800 milligrams of a mixture of acetic acid.
The squish, the aloe vera, verbride,
butarit, butarit, arachidotic acid, grape seed, extract.
Okay, so yeah.
So, it's not saying how much el glutamine it is in there.
So, if you're taking two capsules a day.
So, again, you're taking el glutamine.
So, is el glutamine a good thing to take for cancer?
In general, no.
But, especially, it's even worse if a person's cancer
is driven by glutamine or if a person's colorectal type cancer.
So, if they have a no carcinoma in the colorectal area
or you had been a static cancer of any type
that's in the colorectal area,
then I would say absolutely not, that's a glutamine.
I think this person asked this question as breast cancer,
taking el glutamine, we don't know, maybe there's 400 milligrams
of glutamine in two capsules, because it's a mixture of that.
It's a proprietary blend.
I would think for a share period of time
or something rather than taking it.
So, if your practitioner tested you with kinesiology
and you feel comfortable with that person's testing
and the ability that I would feel bad about taking that.
So, I would go ahead and do that.
When you're testing anything, you might want to just,
you have a local practitioner,
you can ask them to test it again in two weeks and see it test.
So, this has to follow through with, you know,
their care with that, that might be good.
A friend of mine's 16-year-old son was just diagnosed
with high grade glioma, a DIPG tumor.
I know that's a punty glioma in the brain.
That's a fairly fast-growing tumor in the mid-grade.
It's very aggressive.
I didn't see any articles on your blog.
I'd go in the director to do your site,
but I don't want to overwhelm her.
It thought it might be easier to follow an article or podcast
where you've talked about it.
For any other place,
it's good information on this specific cancer.
Everyone, please pray for that.
Please, that's good for you, my dear.
I don't think I have any articles specifically
on contined gliomas.
I know that there's been questions on the Zoom calls
about glioma that it might have broken up into specific videos
on gliomas, not specifically a contined glioma
that I could remember,
but when you're treating glioma of any type,
they still offer a glioma X the same way
to let it where it is.
So maybe just get her on the site information
on the right machine,
because that's gonna be the biggest important factor
for this young guy.
I've had broadened gland pain with eating first bite syndrome
for almost a year and a half.
It's on my left side where the tumors were.
Now lately, the pain has become more intense.
It has lasted longer.
Do you have any suggestions for that?
Well, broadened gland pain.
So what's your broadened gland does
is it secretes enzyme called patellin.
That helps digest your food,
starts with the breakdown of the food.
It's secret saliva.
It's secretes amylase.
It's very important for the initial digestive processes
to take place, signals,
the signaling molecules to the stomach to secret HCl.
If you're a person contacting me,
know history of cancer,
especially the type of cancer that you have
or so ask this question.
Then I would say we need to do some investigation
as far as it's not uncommon to have an autoimmune attack
like a broadened gland.
So we need to do some investigation in that.
However, given your history,
I would be more inclined to look at,
again, no matter what, you're a person's history,
you gotta dig to find out what is the cause.
So there could be many causes of glandular pain
and then you gotta figure out what that is.
Given your history, I would make sure
you contact your oncologist about this
to see to make sure there isn't any metastasis
to the chronic lead or metastasis.
Underneath the chronic lead in that area,
you can be getting your illogical pain
that seems like it's in the product lab
but the cause of it was actually neurological
and there could be a mass or a lesion elsewhere.
So I don't have any specific remedies for this.
I would have, I would say that we just need to dig
a little bit deeper to see what the cause of this is.
Our multiple hangnails, the side or symptom
of a deficiency or other health issue.
Boy, well I remember reading early on
that the hangnails are a side of zinc deficiency.
I'm not sure how true that is.
I do know that multiple hangnails are certainly
common with people that are using chemicals
with their hands, people that are doing work on machinery
and maybe they're getting their hands oily and greasy
and they're having to wash with solvents to get them off.
That's common.
I do know that you can get hangnails because you lose,
you have dry skin around your nails due to using solvents
like that, you can get hangnails
because a person is deficient in fats, fatty acid deficiency
can lead to hangnails issues and skin issues of all kinds.
So I'd investigate those kinds of things.
If this is you, someone's asking this question
and they've done chemo or radiation and things like that,
there's all sorts of other pieces to that puzzle too.
Chemotherapy is going to settle in the tissues
that talks and is going to settle in distal tissues.
That's why you get neuropathies in your feet,
neuropathies in your hands, post chemotherapy.
So it depends on who has this.
Great if you dig to that again.
Okay, chat questions.
I did what you recommended to get my homocysteine level down.
I took clear digest to methyl and B12s a day.
It worked and my homocysteine went down to 6.8.
The integrative doctor who tested me told me
to keep taking two of them per day.
But I remember you saying that this is not a good idea
long-term solution because it could suppress
the other two or suppressor genes.
My question is, what would you recommend
I do going forward to keep the homocysteine down?
I personally would stick on to a day for maybe another month
and then drop to one a day and then give it a month
and retest your homocysteine.
So, important thing when you're looking at blood markers
like this, okay, you have elevated homocysteine.
Danger of homocysteine is that it etches your arteries,
causes cholesterol to clack your arteries
and you can end up with a blockage of an artery.
Not a good thing, we don't need a heart attack
when you're trying to deal with cancer.
So, that trumps the fact that excess methyl groups
can turn off to the suppressor genes.
However, the truth is that is that one adjective excess.
So, excess methyl groups can silence two or suppressor genes.
You may be a person that has just a distinct deficiency
in methyl groups and a need for them to keep homocysteine levels down.
Like I said, you'd go give methyl groups based upon genetics.
You'd give methyl groups based upon genetics.
You'd give methyl groups based upon blood levels of homocysteine.
So, if a person has elevated homocysteine,
that's when you'd give them methyl groups.
A lot of people will go to genetics and they have an MTHFRG defect
and they'll, oh, you need methyl groups.
Here, take this methyl tetrahedral folate,
take this methyl comolomide, you need this.
Why do I need this?
Because you have an MTHFRG defect.
Oh, okay.
And that causes all sorts of problems.
So, not just cancer issues, it causes emotional issues.
It pushes the biopathy pathway.
Do you have any LADFX?
You're going to end up with emotional imbalances,
CLT imbalances, all sorts of problems.
So, you, but you give that based upon functional labs,
which are labs that change, genetics don't change.
The functional labs are labs that change,
the functional labs are labs that change based upon metabolism.
So, you may be a person that needs to stay on methyl groups.
If we could get it down to one a day,
we could make sure you're not getting excess.
That's the whole idea.
We don't want excess.
So, the only way to know is to retake homocysteine levels.
So, it just depends on how comfortable you are
with getting your blood drawn more frequently.
If you're, and cool with that, doesn't bother me.
And I encourage space for it.
Well, then we'll get it drawn every month.
And see if one a day is fine for you.
If it doesn't start climbing back up, you can stay on one a day.
So, that's really the way to treat it.
Do you have any thoughts on the TMAO?
Here's a short excerpt from an article.
My last blood work showed extremely high cholesterol.
My doctor says, if I don't bring it down,
she wants me to do a heart scan radiation involved.
To evaluate a blockage and other risk,
maybe measuring TMAO might be a good alternative.
For instance, in 2014 study,
though the positive.
Okay, so, you can send me that study.
If I have a chance to look at it,
I will gladly look at it.
Send me your lab work, too.
So, I don't know what.
Extremely high cholesterol is defined as by your doctor.
I also would want to know if they just looked at cholesterol,
LDL, HDL,
or did they get into oxidized LDLs and get into,
you know, a more in-depth cardio profile?
Because that's really what tells you whether you're at risk of heart issues.
Not so much your total cholesterol level,
but your inflammatory cholesterol components
is what really tells you where a person is going to have an issue.
So, if you send me your blood work,
I will gladly look at it and then we need to set up a consult
if we do that.
I have a told I will have my updated results.
I will have my MRI of blood,
that kind of next week, these days.
It's taking forever with my doctor, Levy,
and I want to have a comment.
All right, great.
So, send me that as soon as you get that information.
That would be great.
I'm a variant from myeloid.
At the S panel,
I was told this variant indicates
that there's a lot of people in the hospital
who are in the hospital.
Colonyl chemo, polices,
and suggested I stay on top of my cardiology.
Have you heard of this?
No, I'd have to look that up.
But, you may not be.
Polices.
It can be initially.
We do need to look at your panels.
That's where I'm getting.
I know I'm a group on site on our blood site.
Or if you're getting blood work from your doctor,
or if you can get a complete cardio panel.
So, don't feel bad about asking for a complete cardio panel
so that you know what you're in.
True inflammatory cardio.
Does the blood test tell you if you have access back
to the question of methyl groups?
No, it doesn't.
That's why you're going to have to, you know,
play with your dosage.
You can see what, you know,
whatever dosage you can stay at that keeps your,
let's say it this way, the lowest dosage of methyl groups
that keeps your home with cystine love.
In a happy spot is where you want to stay.
I mean, only way to know that because everybody's different, right?
So, the only way to know that is to be regularly checking
the home with cystine levels when you change that dosage.
So, you know, understand you're on a product
that contains x amount of methyl groups, let's say,
I don't know, you know, 1000 milligrams of methyl folate.
I don't know the product that you're on.
And then you're, you're taking, it may be let's say two capsules.
They drop out of the one capsule.
Maybe that's not enough.
Then your home with cystine starts to rise up.
So, you might need to change products to what it has
in between one and two capsules with.
You have to play with that.
Would you please explain about nitric oxide?
And why should we not take it?
I was reading how it's good for metabolism and cardiac health.
Yes, I actually have several blog posts on that.
So, I will refer you to that.
But in general, a lot of things that are good for cardiac health
and a lot of things that are good for general health
aren't necessarily good for a person that has active cancer.
We use the description of antioxidants and oxidants.
But we could also use the description of nitric oxide.
So, nitric oxide is made in your body.
So, understand, you make nitric oxide.
When the person is saying I take nitric oxide,
you're taking exogenous sources of nitric oxide.
Your body actually makes three different types of nitric oxide.
You have cytokine-induced nitric oxide in synthase,
created when you have an immune response.
What it does is it helps with your body to stimulate inflammatory cytokines
to draw in natural killer cells and macrophages
to destroy a pathogen.
The one that nitric oxide works on exogenous nitric oxide
tends to work on what they focus on is NOS3,
which is also called endothelial nitric oxide synthase.
Endothelial nitric oxide synthase works in the smooth muscle
underneath the endothelial layer.
So, the endothelial cells are the cells that line your blood vessels.
So, the smooth muscle underneath the endothelial cells
when nitric oxide attaches to the receptor,
it causes those smooth vessels to relax.
Full name for that used to be called relaxin.
Used to be thought it was a horrible.
Now we know it's nitric oxide synthase.
Endothelial nitric oxide synthase that reacts with that.
You take exogenous nitric oxide,
it will do the same thing.
So, it can relax those smooth muscles there by opening up the vessels.
Thereby decrease in a person's blood pressure.
So, person has blood pressure issues you can take nitric oxide
and it will decrease your blood pressure.
So, the only issue with that is that it's been found
that it also increases vascular endothelial growth factor,
which is a good thing, right?
Endothelial nitric oxide synthase stimulates vascular endothelial growth factor,
which stimulates new blood vessel laid out,
which is a good thing for your heart,
but it's not a good thing for especially a solid cancer.
So, if you have a tuber in your breast and you're taking nitric oxide,
exogenous nitric oxide because your work out captain told you to take it.
It's really good for your heart and it's really good for your bloodstream.
It's really good for all this.
Well, yeah, it is, but it's not good for your cancer,
because it could increase growth of blood vessels into the cancer,
feeding the cancer, causing the cancer to grow.
So, not a good thing for somebody who has cancer.
There's also other negatives to taking the exogenous nitric oxide.
So, they will go into detail here,
but it's questionable now.
So, you know, taking too much of it could be an issue as well.
Plus, you know, if you have blood pressure issues or something,
just thinking that why just need to take more nitric oxide,
that's going to be solved with problem without dealing with the cause of the problem,
because you have to deal with the cause of it.
What is causing the contraction of the swollen muscles in the first place?
So, this is where you get into what they've discovered
is some of the most common causes,
is H. Polaroid, is Lyme disease,
it's heavy metal toxicity, other chemical toxicities,
and that's really what you want to deal with.
So, yeah, I have more about that on some blog posts.
Now, I have an extra rife machine.
Do you have a care package where you program the rife for my friend's son,
with the brain tumor, and send a laptop down.
Yes, we do.
So, we have people that were gifted a rife machine from a friend,
or something like that.
Yeah, just have them call the office,
and we could figure something out.
They have to do a case review.
So, let's start with that.
I've heard that if my tumor becomes a product,
it's still dangerous and needs to be removed,
so there's a risk of sepsis.
Well, yeah, whatever any tissue becomes the product,
there is a risk of sepsis
because that the closest can lead into other extracellular spaces.
And you're going to have endotoxin issues
and impossible infection that goes along with that.
Yeah, so it doesn't mean that you absolutely need to have it removed.
We have people that have an awful looking breasts that have not had it removed,
and it's awful looking breasts from the product breasts.
So, the product in the product tumor has,
they've been able to topically deal with it and tell a wound,
um, chilled over quite well,
and then there's still gold strong years later.
So, um, if you do have an infection
or you have an open wound that is constantly has a risk of infection
and you're not dealing with it copically very well,
yeah, your risk does go up with that,
but, you know, you have risks, lot of risks in life too.
There's risks of doing surgery too,
so you've got to weigh which risk is worse for you.
Do you think that estrogen really feeds breast cancer?
I haven't gotten the shot yet.
Maybe next week, do you think that cutting down my estrogen really is the solution?
I'm only pursuing this route because I don't know what other options I have.
So, does estrogen feed a breast cancer?
So, does estrogen feed an estrogen receptor positive cancer?
Um, no, it doesn't feed it.
The definition of estrogen receptor positive cancer is that,
uh, that these estrogens attack,
so you could, you could have bad estrogens that can be a cause of cancer.
Okay, so, but that's not what we're talking about with ER positive cancer.
So, anything that gets inside of the cell that can be oxidative to the nucleus of the cell
that can damage the nucleus and cause the cell to go and replicate interrapid replication is a cause of cancer.
That's not what we're talking about when we're talking about estrogen receptor positive cancer.
Estrogen receptor positive cancers or progesterone receptor or her two positive cancers are when estrogens are attaching to the data receptor
on the cell membrane.
The beta estrogen receptor on the cell membrane used to be called the needle receptor is an apoptotic receptor.
So, remember, how does a cell die?
So, a cell dies normally through the process of what's called apoptosis,
which is really a recycling of the cell matter, the cell blebs in on itself.
Yes, that's the proper term blebby.
Blebs in on itself and through the other other cell organelles, the lysosomes and the ribosomes,
it helps to basically digest what's inside the cell in the cell.
Some of the cell components are reutilized and used by other cells.
So, that is normal programed cell down, apoptosis.
But apoptosis is stimulated through multiple different pathways.
You have an intrinsic apoptanet pathway, which means something happens inside the cell that stimulates the cell to die.
That is when we talk about tumor suppressor genes, tumor suppressor genes stimulate that intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
And I think I go into this in depth.
I think I made some videos on this a number of years ago, it's the capsaic pathways.
And so, if a person has something that damages the nucleus and the cell starts to go into rapid replication and believe me,
this probably happens daily, at least weekly, to every human being.
If that happens to a healthy cell, something gets inside the cell, damages the nucleus, the cell goes into rapid replication.
It will stimulate your tumor suppressor genes and your tumor suppressor genes stimulate the intrinsic apoptonic pathways.
That means from the inside of the cell, the cell realizes this is wrong, this is in rapid replication, we need to kill ourselves.
And it causes this self-destruction, this apoptotic, from the inside out process, intrinsic apoptotic stimulation through tumor suppressor stimulation.
There's also what's called the extrinsic pathways.
So you have extrinsic pathways, vitamin D actually can stimulate the extrinsic pathway.
And the et al or beta receptor on the cell membrane is a apoptotic pathway that's extrinsically stimulated by vitamin D attaching to that receptor.
Now it can't attach that receptor if it's being blocked by estrogen.
So if estrogen is blocking that receptor, it doesn't allow stimulation of the apoptotic pathway that way.
I understand that's only one way a cancer dies, but it is one way.
So by getting your estrogen levels down, you remove the burden of estrogen's attaching to that receptor and you increase the likelihood of extrinsic apoptonic pathways being stimulated.
I would agree, I think, yes, there's benefit to removing estrogen, to lowering estrogen levels.
And you can't dispute that, you've had people, you know, thousands, thousands of women that have gone on estrogen blocking medication and the cancer did shrink.
The truth is there are thousands of women that went on and didn't shrink either, because it's not the only way a cancer cell dies.
So, but there is benefit to doing that, can't argue that.
So, is it worth giving it a try?
I think so.
I think it is worth giving it a try.
And I think that you'll know in a short period of time, a lot of women will try it and they'll do it for a couple of months.
So, it's, you know, it's hard, yes, some women can bounce back and the rest of the levels can come back pretty good and they, their symptoms go away, some people it takes longer.
But it can be worth a try.
So, it is something to consider.
So, I did want to address some people ask a question on the Zoom call and put their question in beforehand, which is great.
And then I answer that question and then the next week, I notice they submit the question again.
If that happens, and I answered it on last week's Zoom call, then I'm not going to answer it again, because you guys are going to think it's losing my memory or something.
Let me just answer that question last week.
So, please look back on the last week's question.
If somebody asked a question a couple of weeks ago, and they jumped on the call like 20 minutes late, and I had already answered the question.
So, I get it. They didn't take the answer. They're questions. So, they asked it again.
But I won't answer it again.
So, just look back on the recording.
I have a far infrared heating pad from your store.
Can I use it since I have a pacemaker? Yeah, it should be fine.
Yeah, it's not. I mean, maybe I wouldn't put it right over my heart.
But you could use it over your liver.
We'll think there's be a problem. It's not an electrical pulse or anything.
After I submit a question, the question remains in my box. I have to delete the previous question first.
Oh, sure. Yeah. So, some people can ask the question accidentally, as much as you're saying.
I get it. No, it's no. I don't care if you ask me both the same question.
I just don't want you to think I'm rude that I don't answer in your question this week.
And this has only happened a couple of times, but I still want people to think I'm rude and not answering their question.
If I actually did answer their question last week and they worked on the Zoom call,
or they came in late, so that's all I did.
So, I don't think there's a time that I did answer a question from the people sent in.
So, I just want you to go that down.
But I'm getting good.
My best answer your questions.
Anything else.
Okay, we will see you guys next week.
And again, the person that asked that question about the lab.
Alright, God bless everybody. Bye bye.